walking by her husband's side my aasaiya
to Barney in less troubled times the
first lady in yellow has been charged
with the murder of the Prime Minister's
first wife the case is testing the
division of powers between the judiciary
and the government suppose she is found
guilty and she is convicted of murder
I think for a suit that would be a first
step that would teach everyone that
would be a lesson for every citizen
especially people in influential
positions of power that they they are
not immune to justice I have the bending
desire I'm zillah's to see where we have
the first lady like any other mo so -
I'm expecting that she must as well go
they're being trashed and if knitter
eyes go to jail Dipple a lota Barney was
gunned down outside her home in June
2017 an armed gang was initially blamed
the killing occurred just two days
before Thomas - Barney was sworn in for
his second spell as p.m. he'd not only
been fighting an election campaign but
also a bitter divorce against it balelo
at its heart a power struggle for who
was the rightful first lady a battle for
influence in the country last month
lawsuit whose police commissioner linked
Thomas to Barney's mobile phone - a call
at the time of the murder
the prime minister was himself then
questioned by police but he hasn't been
charged the story has sparked intrigue
and anger in the normally peaceful
country protesters want tibarn a to quit
as Prime Minister immediately so far
he's only said he'll step down at some
point because of old age he's 80
but even if he leaves office questions
about what really happened to his first
wife and the quest for justice all
remain for more on the developments of
this case I'm joined by journalists in
Tirana
in Catania who's reporting from
whistlers capital massero hello in
Tirana good to see you obviously
hot-off-the-press I see you in the car
making your way from that coat but tell
us a little bit of
what happened in court today as I
understand it the formality of actually
laying the charge happened that's
correct we know now not that my Zayat
Abani the prime minister's wife has been
charged with the murder of his second
wife tipo de la Habana in 2017 as well
as the attempted murder of Tata Sabula
this is de Palermo stefani de poner la
Habana is friend who was with her in the
car who was shot but survived of course
people who died in that shooting she
fled to South African last month to
escape arrest why has she now turned
herself in from what we understand when
she fled in the suit to South Africa it
was to the knowledge of the security
agencies in South Africa and
subsequently through negotiation the
South African envoy of President Cyril
Ramaphosa with the state security mr.
deputy state security minister went to
suit but nothing transpired from that
but following that we then understand
that the South African security agencies
gave her an ultimatum to either leave
South Africa or be arrested in South
Africa as you can understand the two
countries have an extradition treaty
between them that allows them to
exchange people who are wanted in either
country and as a result that would have
had to happen for her to go to the suit
however because she was a fugitive from
justice who was already wanted when she
fled Lesotho South African authorities
could in fact arrest her and take her -
so - as opposed to avoid that her lawyer
then advised her to go and report
herself to the police which she did
yesterday and where is the Prime
Minister stand in all of this and is he
going to step down as many in the
country are calling for well Christine
what we know is that the Prime Minister
was first written to by the Commissioner
of Police hala mammootty Brady who
informed him that his cellphone is the
one that was actually called by people
at the scene where de pelota bonny was
shot and killed in 2017 so from what we
understood he would have been the first
person had to be suspected of this crime
however because Mars Maserati bonnie has
parked
declared that her and a husband share
cellphones and we suppose that because
of other investigations that have now
pointed more to her than to him now it
appears that she is the first accused in
this case however what we can say is
that the Prime Minister has been absent
and fired in even in court today he was
in prison so very cos because by his
absence in terms of stepping down we
suppose that this case probably is the
main reason why he feels that he needs
to step aside but he still hasn't done
that we know that he says he will retire
when Parliament has started processes
for him to do so and we are waiting for
that to happen to see when he actually
does step down Christine all right
that's and Doug wanna got sunny in this
is capital massero for us thank you